lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es ver las diferentes formas que hay
para representar a una molécula la forma
más obvia es mediante su nombre
por ejemplo podríamos estar nos
refiriendo a una molécula de benceno
benceno sin embargo la palabra benceno
nos dice muy poco acerca de lo que
compone esta molécula aunque hay otros
nombres que dan más información pero a
lo mejor ustedes están interesados en
conocer cuáles son los elementos que
forman esta molécula en este caso nos
serviría un poco más conocer la fórmula
empírica fórmula empírica y quizá
ustedes se pregunten bueno que significa
empírico en general la palabra empírico
se refiere a algo que viene de la
observación y la experimentación se
puede decir que mediante evidencia
empírica ahora sabemos esto en general
significa que se ha observado
información al respecto y es por eso que
ahora nosotros podemos tener este
conocimiento y la razón por la que estas
fórmulas en particular se llama fórmula
empírica es porque los primeros químicos
no tenían forma de observar una sola
molécula pero si podíamos observar la
proporción que tenían las moléculas de
los diferentes elementos
una fórmula empírica nos va a dar una
proporción de los elementos en esa
molécula así que la fórmula empírica
para el benceno es un carbono por un
hidrógeno y bueno ahora ustedes pueden
decir que si están trabajando con el
benceno van a tener un átomo de carbono
por cada átomo de hidrógeno o un átomo
de hidrógeno por cada átomo de carbono
pero cuántos de esos elementos tenemos
realmente en una molécula de benceno
para responder a esta pregunta tenemos
que ver la fórmula molecular y esta
fórmula molecular del benceno nos va a
dar mucha más información al respecto al
menos comparada con la fórmula empírica
y esta fórmula nos dice que cada
molécula de benceno tiene 6 átomos de
carbono y 6 átomos de hidrógeno
la proporción sigue siendo la misma uno
a uno como está aquí y es bastante
sencillo pasar de la fórmula molecular a
la fórmula empírica esencialmente se
pierde algo de la información excepto la
proporción aquí tenemos la proporción de
6 a 6 que es lo mismo que una proporción
de 1 a 1
si quisiéramos podríamos escribir esto
como c 1 h 1 ya que la proporción por
cada carbono que se tiene se tiene un
hidrógeno pero en una molécula por cada
6 carbonos que tenemos hay 6 hidrógenos
se sigue conservando la misma proporción
pero a lo mejor ustedes quieren saber
más quieren saber cómo es que estos seis
carbonos y estos seis hidrógenos están
unidos entre sí bueno para esto van a ir
a la fórmula estructural fórmula
estructural la cual nos va a dar
obviamente la estructura de en este caso
una molécula de benceno una molécula de
benceno se va a dibujar así 6 carbonos
en un hexágono 12
456 carbonos en un hexágono así y aquí
vamos a tener un enlace doble de manera
salteada en este hexágono 1 si uno no
uno si uno no y cada uno de estos
carbonos va a estar enlazado a un
hidrógeno cada una de estas líneas que
estoy dibujando simboliza un enlace un
enlace covalente que veremos con mucho
más detalle en otros vídeos pero
esencialmente significa que comparten
electrones es lo que hace que estos
carbonos permanezcan juntos y hacen que
cada hidrógeno esté unido a un carbono
así que lo dibujamos así y esta es sólo
una variante de las fórmulas
estructurales las fórmulas estructurales
de strong les dan información
tridimensional de las moléculas les
puede decir si una molécula se sale o se
mete hacia la página y otras fórmulas
estructurales puede que no sean tan
explícitas como está una vez que entran
a la química orgánica las cadenas de
carbono se representan así por ejemplo
el benceno se representaría así donde
los carbonos están
lícitos en los vértices o en las
esquinas de este dibujo y bueno sabemos
que un carbono típico va a tener cuatro
enlaces para que esté en un estado
estable y aquí vemos 1 2 3 y si no está
dibujado el cuarto enlace pues debe
haber una hidrógeno y esa es la
convención que usan las personas en la
química orgánica así que existen muchas
formas de dibujar una fórmula
estructural sin embargo esta es una
forma muy típica como ven vamos a tener
más información conforme vamos a usando
la fórmula empírica y pasamos a la
fórmula molecular y finalmente a la
fórmula estructural ahora quiero hacer
énfasis en que las fórmulas empíricas y
las fórmulas moleculares no siempre son
diferentes a veces las proporciones
muestran las cantidades reales de cada
elemento en una molécula un buen ejemplo
de esto es el agua escribimos agua en el
agua nosotros sabemos que por cada dos
hidrógenos tenemos un oxígeno y resulta
que esto que escribí en términos de la
fórmula empírica que muestra solamente
proporciones de hecho es el caso que en
una molécula de agua
hay dos átomos de hidrógeno y uno de
oxígeno si queremos ver la fórmula
estructural que quizá ustedes ya la
hayan visto por ahí cada oxígeno en una
molécula de agua va a estar unido a dos
hidrógenos espero que con esto ustedes
comiencen a apreciar las diferentes
maneras de representar una molécula nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo